you write in your book uh that the entry
for our reality in the hitchhiker's
guide
might read a physical universe whose
intrinsic nature is constituted of
consciousness
worth a visit
so
our
whole conversation has been about the
first part of that sentence what about
the second part
worth the visit
why is this place worth a visit
why does it have meaning
why does it have value at all why
these are big questions
i mean firstly i do think pan psychism
it
is important to think about for
considerations of
meaning and value as we've already
discussed i
i think consciousness is the root of
everything that matters in life you know
from
deep emotions subtle thoughts
beautiful
sensory experiences
and yet i i believe our official
scientific world view
is incompatible with the reality of
consciousness uh
i mean that's controversial but that's
what i think and i think people feel
this on an intuitive level
it's maybe part of what max weber called
the disenchantment of nature you know
that they think
they know
their feelings and experiences are not
just electrochemical signaling i mean
they might just have that very informed
intuition but i think that can be
rigorously supported so i think this can
lead to a sense of alienation and
a sense that we lack a framework
for understanding the meaning and
significance of our lives and um
in the absence of that people turn to
other things to make sense of the
meaning of their lives like you know
nationalism fundamentalist religion
consumerism
so i think pan psychism is important in
that regard in bringing together the
quantitative facts of physical science
with the as it were the human truth by
you know by which i just mean the
qualitative reality of our own
experience
um
as i've already said i do i do think
there are objective
facts about
value and
what we ought to do and what we ought to
believe that we respond to is and that's
very mysterious to make sense of both
how there could be such facts and how we
could know about them and respond to
them but
um
i do think there are such facts and
they're mostly to do with kinds of
conscious experience
so they're there to be discovered and
much of the
human condition is to discover those
objective sources of value i think so
yeah and then i mean moving away from
pan psyches into the you know
at an even bigger level i suppose i i
i think it is important to me
to live in hope that there's a there's a
purpose to existence
and that you know what what i do
contributes in some small way to that
greater purpose and but you know i
i would say i don't i don't know if
there's a purpose to existence i think
some some things point in that direction
some things point away from it
but
i don't think you need certainty or even
even high probability
to
have faith in something so taken take an
analogy suppose you've got a friend
who's very seriously ill maybe there's
a 30 chance they're gonna make it
you shouldn't believe your friend's
gonna get better
you know because but probably not but
what you can say is you know you could
say to your friend i have faith that
you're gonna get better that is i i
choose to
live in hope about that about that
possibility i choose to orientate my
life towards that hope
similarly you know
i don't think we know whether or not
there's a purpose to existence but i
think we can make the choice to
live in hope of that possibility and i i
find that
a worthwhile
um
and fulfilling way to live so maybe as
your editor i would uh
collaborate with you on the edit of the
hitchhiker's guide entry
that instead of worth the visit
we'll we'll insert
hopefully worth a visit
[Laughter]
or the inhabitants hoped
that you would think
it's worth a visit uh philip you're an
incredible mind an incredible human
being and indeed are humble
um
and
i'm really happy that you're able to uh
argue and take on some of these
difficult questions with uh some of the
most uh brilliant people in the world
which are the philosophers thinking
about the human mind so this was an
awesome conversation i hope you continue
talking to folks like sam harris i'm so
glad you talked to joe i uh
can't wait to see what you write what
you say what you think next thank you so
much for talking today thanks very much
alex this has been a really fascinating
conversation i've i've got a lot i need
to think about actually just from this
conversation but thanks for thanks for
chatting to me
you